now we have a mantel and hansel who
developed in 1959 the log rank test
which is
as we'll see is kind of the analogy of
the t-test for survival data so we know
we know how to treat how to look at one
sample how to summarize it now let's
move up the two samples the so-called
log-rank test so
again we're looking at brain cancer data
and we have
males and females who want to compare
their survival
well let's start with the capital minor
curves here they are
blue is female and green is male
and it looks like there's a slight
advantage for females here the question
is is it significant we've all got 88
patients so we don't know whether this
is actually
a real effect or just maybe
within the noise
so yes females seem to fair a little
better up to 50 months
but then both the curves level off
around 50
how can we carry out a test of the two
survival curves
again it looks like you know when we
hear two samples we think of t-test
but again the sensoring creates a
complication right
so to overcome the challenge we'll
conduct what's called the log rank test
and logarithmic text actually is very
much has the same kind of structure as
kaplan-meier it's going to proceed it's
going to sum up things over the the
failure times
so let's call the unique failure times
or death times d1 through dk
let rk be the number of patients at risk
at dk and qk the number of patients who
died at dk
and the number at risk
at
dk we'll call r1k and r2k in the two
groups right in this case males and
females so so rob the rk
is the number of patients who died at
time dk so you're assuming that more
than one person can diet at this time i
think he said r
at risk and and qk right qk is the
number you died right so it is yeah it
is possible some studies especially if
the time is sort of measured discretely
maybe not by days by months you can have
more than one patient dying at a given
time i think okay in the simplest case
qk will be one or will be one yeah
basically but the log rank test can
easily
seamlessly handle the case where there's
tide survival times okay
and this just says the number of
patients the total number of patients at
risk are called rk and the hormone diet
qk
okay so what i just said as we summarize
in this table
here's the two groups say males and
females
here's the number that died again
normally there'll be a one of these
would be a one the other will be a zero
but it's possible to have uh so this is
this is a special little table just for
the death time at dk exactly right so
we're looking at the whole sort of
process but we're it's a cross section
saying okay at one time dk
this is what we see
and we're going to have such a table for
each dk
and we said this already if the death
time is unique then then one of these is
a one and the other's a zero
okay
so how do we use this table now to
construct a test statistic to test
whether
the two groups are the same their
survival is is the same well in general
if you have a random variable x what you
do is you and you want to test whether
the mean of x is zero what you do is you
you take x you and you center it by the
the expectation of x under the null
hypothesis h zero and you divide by its
standard deviation so the x here we're
going to use is we're going to use the
the the sum of the
number of people that died in the top
left table in other words let me go back
here
right
if group one is much worse than group
two and survival we expect to see a lot
of ones here and a lot of zeros here
right and vice versa for group two
so you want to see whether
the number of the total number of people
who died
in group one at each risk set
is it large compared to what we expect
it to be
if they had the same
survival rate exactly
so this gets
a little complicated and the the details
are in the text but essentially we're
going to sum up over wrist sets
the the number in the top left corner
that's the number that died in group 1
minus what we'd expect to see if the two
groups were the same
divided by its standard deviation and
what we expect to see the two groups the
same is just the total number of risks
times the proportion that we're in group
one
right so so r1k is the total number at
risk in in the first group exactly but
the proportion is over the it's the
merge groups right that it's the the
total deaths
irrespective of group so that's the
proportion overall right and so you want
to see if it's just divided up
proportionally exactly yeah
and that nasty thing in the bottom is
the standard deviation yes the variance
yeah the details of which are in the
book we don't need to
bore you with this right now and then
it's summed over all the
the death tones exactly yeah right so
you're saying on the on the average is
the number of people we see in group one
the die is it more more or less than
we'd expect if the two groups were the
same
and as is always the case is often the
case in statistics when one forms a
normalized test statistic
what you do is you say well if the
sample size is large this is going to be
approximately normal 0 1 standard normal
distribution so we can look at a normal
table we can compare the w to a normal
table
and to determine whether what we're
seeing is departure large enough that we
would or would not expect it by chance
let me get a p value from that
okay okay let's see what it does
well not too exciting the log rank gave
a w of 1.2
and with a corresponding two-sided
p-value of 0.2
why are we using a two-sided p-value
here trevor
oh
that's a surprise question statistics
101.
well we'd just be we'd be equally
surprised if if the male survival time
was worse than the females or vice versa
and so you know we don't want to look at
the result and then just test what we
see right we you know our priori we
weren't we'd be surprised either
direction right so it makes the test uh
more objective more unbiased otherwise
we'd be favoring as where our null
hypothesis is okay
so overall we can't reject the null
hypothesis of no difference in survival
occurs right because the p-value is not
very small but as we've seen in the
course this doesn't mean necessary there
is no difference it could mean that we
don't have much power to find that
difference maybe our study wasn't big
enough in particular
we had 88 patients maybe if we had 8 000
patients we could there may be a
difference 88 patients in total right
some were censored many were censored
that's a good point um
the real sample size in survival
analysis isn't so much the actual sample
size but the number of events right
because the sensor observations provide
partial information but only a little
bit they helped in the denominators
right but we were counting them a number
of deaths right those were in the 30s
total and uh divided by two groups so
right quite small that's always
important remember survival analysis the
sample size isn't quite what it seems
so that's the log rank test it's closely
related to cox's proportional hazards
model which we discussed next
okay so we've seen the one sample and
how to summarize it with a capital meyer
we've seen the two sample problem where
we use the log rank test and now we'll
move up to regression which is sort of a
more general more commonly occurring
situation
okay so again we have our survival time
and we observe the minimum of the actual
survival time and the censoring time
well again if you think about it as a
regression a supervised learning problem
we would be tempted maybe not to regress
y on x
or maybe since y has a long right tail
typically being a survival time maybe
log y
but again the sensoring creates a
problem we can't just do that because we
don't we don't know how to deal with the
sensoring
okay
so we're going to use a sequential
construction similar to the idea used in
the kaplan-meier curve and you'll see
this coming up all the time survival
analysis you think of as a process that
unfolds in time and you model it
sort of time point by time point failure
time by failure time
so we've seen that for capital meyer
we've done that for log rank and now for
discretion one thing
that's maybe worth saying the
kaplan-meier curve
it's it's you know it's like a
distribution function which you just fit
to your data in other words we say it's
non-parametric it doesn't really make
any assumptions right but it does take
into account the the censoring
and from that point of view it's
attractive
right and maybe
while you bring this in is that this the
next method proportional hazards model
we'll see right now
carries that theme on basically it's got
sort of a semi-parametric component
which which makes it quite robust to
to departures from from the from
modeling assumptions
so let's see how this works so before we
get there we need to learn sort of a new
uh quantity that the hazard rate or
hazard function i warned you
uh also known as the force of mortality
so what is it well let's look at so this
is a again it's a theoretical quantity
this is a
a function of the of the random variable
t it's a probability that the t
falls between t and t plus delta given t
is greater than t
as delta t equals zero it's kind of a
derivative but what it's saying is
it's a probability of dying in the next
instant
from now given you've survived up to
this time
okay so that's why it's called the force
of mortality kind of a scary quantity
for
people our age getting up there
turns out that if you know the survival
distribution you can just compute this
quantity it's just another way of
representing that right so the the
survival the s of t is actually as
trevor said you can there's a one-to-one
mapping between the hazard and the
survivor function but this turns out to
be a convenient quantity for for the
model that comes up next the
proportional hazards model
and this is due to david cox in a very
famous paper in 1972
which has now become
known as the proportional hazards model
okay
so what is the proportional hazards
model okay again
the point of this section is a
regression that we want to model
covariates or features and how they
affect the outcome
so there's our features x x i j that's
then x i is for observation i and
feature j we've got p such features
now we're going to assume that the
hazard for an individual with features x
i at time t
is some what's called a baseline hazard
function that's unspecified
times this factor
okay well what's the exponential doing
here well the hazard function has to be
positive right it's a probability
so the exponential the main reason for
it there is to make this a positive
quantity
so this hazard now is the it's a hazard
function
for an individual with
features x i
if x is zero we get the baseline hazard
so what this is saying is the hazard for
for an individual who's got a certain
feature is some common hazard that
everybody has times a factor which
either increases or decreases his hazard
depending on whether the betas or pods
are negative
and the beauty of this model is that
that common hazard we're not going to
really make too many assumptions about
it it's just going to be sort of like
the kaplan meyer in a way it's just you
know it's going to be a non-parametric
exactly and we'll see how that's done in
a couple slides
so this quantity is is called the
relative risk for this feature vector
right
the relative risk if we have an
individual with these feature values
compared to an individual with all zero
that's the baseline
the ratio of their hazards is this
second quantity
that's why it's called the relative risk
if this is 1.2 for example it says an
individual with these features
is 1.2 times as likely to die as an
individual with these feature values in
the next instance in the next right
actually actually at all time right at
all times and all time okay because
that's oh there's no there's no time to
depend on t exactly
and as as
like we've said and trevor said that
what this model is saying is it makes no
assumptions about the functional form of
the baseline hazard
which is very nice it means it can adapt
itself to to a lot of different
situations without having to specify
exactly the
hazard for the baseline individual
makes it flexible
the only assumption is that the features
come in as a factor that increase or
decreases the relative risk by a
constant factor depending on the
parameters of course these parameters
we're going to estimate from data just
like we did in in regression rob wasn't
one of your very first papers on
cox's proportional hazards model uh
that's right uh when i was still a
graduate student and working at a
medical center a a doctor i was working
with didn't understand the model and he
said you should write a very he was
british he said he should write a very
simple
explanation of proportional hazards so i
wrote a paper called a plain man's guide
to the proportional hazards model a
lovely paper
actually i'm kind of proud of it still
it was no i wasn't being physician
it really islam okay so
i should read it sometime
just kidding um
so here's an example of proportional
hazards just to sort of reinforce what
it's really saying let's take the
simplest case where we have a single
covariate and it's zero one so it's a
two group case right maybe males and
females or whatever okay
here's the hazard function the log
hazard functions and the survival
probability
for
it says here x i equals zero is
green and x equals one is black
proportional hazards means the gap
between these two hat log hazards is a
constant
right
it also turns out to imply that the
survival curves
don't cross
and we see example here as time goes on
they get farther and farther apart
but they don't cross
so there's the proportionalities for the
hazard the one on the left
when you map it back to the survival
function it's a different kind of
relationship right it's a it's it's it's
in the book but it's a little more
complicated it's since the model is
expressed in terms of the hazard then
the on the log scale you see this
constant gap
over here the gap's not constant but it
doesn't cross
the other hand if we have a situation
like this where the hazards cross
this group's doing better for a while
and then worse later
then the survival curves also cross and
this is a non-proportional hazard
situation
so proportional hazards model
without modification
can't really capture this situation
so it's a convenient assumption yeah
which is often reasonable it's often
reasonable and there are ways to check
it and we just talk in the book a bit
about that and with references but it's
a good starting model it's often very
very effective